Transylvania is like CATALONIA with vampires.
Yep, you heard that right.
The land where Dracula was born is also the
place of one of the most significant separatists
conflicts in all of Europe.
In other words…
Transylvania is the perfect place to make
a VisualPolitik Halloween special.
And…
yes, I know what you are thinking.
We read your comments and we know you want
a video about Catalonia...
And I’ll tell you what!
We are going make it, it’s just big, and
it’s complicated, and I promise it will
be worth the wait…
For now, let’s get back to Transylvania,
a historical region situated in the centre
of Romania.
Despite being in this country, 20% of its
population doesn’t even speak Romanian.
Instead, Hungarian is their mother language.
In some areas, the number of Hungarian-speaking
people rises to 80%.
This area where the Hungarians are the majority
is called as SZEKELY LAND.
Almost every year you can see massive protests
of Szekelies demanding more autonomy for their
territory.
These demonstrations are celebrated in the
main cities of Transylvania as well as Bucharest,
the Romanian capital, and Budapest, the Hungarian
capital.
But wait a minute because things are far more
complicated that they seem!
In fact, Szekelys don’t want to have their
own country.
Instead, they want to become a special region
inside of Romania, with a very specific fiscal
system.
So the question here is…
Why does this cause so many problems for Romania?
Why are these demands causing such a significant
diplomatic conflict?
And more importantly…
What does the Hungarian government have to
do with this?
Well, today we are going to answer all of
these questions.
But before we do that let’s take a look
at the history.
HAIRY TONGUES
For centuries, Transylvania was part of the
Kingdom of Hungary.
Back then, Romania wasn’t even a country.
The upper classes and the aristocracy spoke
Hungarian and Romanian was the language spoken
by the peasants.
At some points in history, Romanian speakers
were even prosecuted by the authorities.
We call this process the MAGYARIZATION.
Basically, the Hungarian rulers wanted to
impose their culture at any cost.
To those aristocrats, Romanians were sort
of hillbillies who had a special love for
stealing things and a bad sense of personal
hygiene...
In fact, there was even a term to refer these
Romanians...
They were called Szőrös nyelvu which, literally
means, ‘with a hairy tongue’.
During the 19th century, the Government closed
Romanian speaking newspapers and they even
forced a lot of citizens to change their Romanian
name to a Hungarian one.
Nonetheless, things changed after the end
of World War I.
The Austro-Hungarian empire lost the war.
And one of the things that happens when you
lose a war is that you usually lose parts
of your territory too.
One of those parts was Transylvania, which
was incorporated into Romania.
Suddenly, those peasants that were oppressed
by the Hungarian nobility had power.
And, well, they wanted revenge.
This is how the first attempts to destroy
the Hungarian culture started.
And oh boy, it
was not an easy job…
Don’t forget that, despite being part of
Romania, Transylvania was the home of over
1 million Hungarian speaking people.
These were called the SZEKELIS and for generations
have been speaking the language of ISTVAN
ORKENY.
But things got really a lot uglier during
World War II.
Hungary once again chose the wrong side to
ally with.
With Hitler’s help, they took back their
former territories and struck back against
those who wanted to erase Hungarian culture
in the country.
As you can imagine, this helped to make the
Romanians even more angry.
Then, in 1945, the Germans lost the war.
That included their allies and, of course,
the Hungarians.
So Romania, with a brand new communist government
took Transylvania back.
This time, with an even bigger taste for a
payback.
Maybe you remember this other video where
I told you about the dictatorship of Nicolae
Ceausescu?
If you have seen it, you already know the
Communist Romania was the closest thing to
a European North Korea.
1 out of 30 Romanians were part of the political
police, and they prosecuted not only those
who opposed the government, but even those
who dared to speak Hungarian.
From one day to the other, Ceaucescu closed
newspapers and forced those Szekelys to speak
Romanian even in their own homes.
Magyarization, bad as it was, forced a few
Romanians to change their names.
Romanization was the same sort of thing, just
on a way bigger scale.
But hold on a minute because it doesn’t
stop here!
On their path to destroy even the last resemblance
of Hungarian culture, the Romanian Communist
Party forced thousands of citizens to set
in the Hungarian speaking territories.
This way, Hungarian speaking became a small
minority in cities like ORADEA or SATU MARE.
Basically, the whole area that borders with
Hungary became a Romanian majority region.
Nonetheless, there is a region that managed
to keep their language and traditions in tact,
and that is the so-called SZEKELY LAND.
ROMANIA STEALS FROM US!
In 1991, Romania passed their brand new democratic
constitution.
This constitution recognized the right to
speak Hungarian.
But, as you can imagine, after decades of
hate against Budapest, those szekelys were
far from happy.
Think about it, fiscally, Romania is a very
centralized country.
Almost all the taxes are collected by the
central government and then, they share that
money among the regions, with a focus on the
poorest ones.
This puts Transylvania in a very bad position,
and that’s because they are wealthier than
the other regions...
And this, well this, is how a new political
party was born: the Democratic Alliance of
Hungarians of Romania, also known as the UDMR.
Unsurprisingly, they won all the elections
in regions where Hungarians are the majority...
So, what are their foundations?
Basically, they claim Romania is sucking their
blood… and their money.
Yes… it is the same as in the Catalonian
case!
And their solution to end Romanian looting
is… imitating the fiscal model of another
Spanish region: the BASQUE country.
Let me explain to you what happens here for
a moment.
The Basque Country is a region inside of Spain
with a very special tax system.
Unlike the other regions, the Basque citizens
don’t pay their taxes to Madrid but to their
local government instead.
Once the money is collected, the local government
has to give some share to the central government.
But the rest is to be managed the way the
local government wants…
Alright, so back to Transylvania.
So, this was the system proposed by the Szekelys
in 2014.
And guess what the Romanian government replied…
Well, they say it was against the constitution.
The Romanian Constitution starts by saying
that that is a sovereign, unitary and in-di-vi-si-ble
country.
Of course, this created lots of protests in
different cities.
There were referendum attempts and all sorts
of other symbolic objection...
These are all things that hurt the Romanian
ruling class.
ROMANIA’S RULING PARTY THREATENS AUTONOMY-SEEKING
TRANSYLVANIAN-HUNGARIANS WITH PRISON PUNISHMENT
Attempts that threaten the constitutional
order of Romania should be punished with prison.
If you’ve been following the case of the
Catalonian separatists, this might sound familiar
to you...
Well, hold on a second because the best is
still yet to come..
AUTONOMY OR ANEXION?
If anybody of you has ever been to Hungary,
I’m sure you might have seen someone wearing
a T-Shirt with this map.
It represents the shape of Hungary before
losing part of their territories before the
World War I. Yes, even today, in the 21st
century, a lot of Hungarians keep dreaming
about taking their old empire back.
Among them there is their president, VIKTOR
ORBAN, the Vladimir Putin of the Danube.
Just like the Russian President, Orban is
famous for prosecuting the journalists who
dare to criticize him.
He has passed anti gay-laws and wins elections
with over 60% the vote.
And, of course, like every good ‘Putinist,’
Orban likes to rule not only his own country,
but others too.
“Orban supports the autonomy of the szekelis”
OK, I know what you are thinking…
Why does a President from another country
mess with the internal politics of another?
At the end of the day, what the Szekelys want
is just to have more autonomy but… without
leaving Romania, right?
Well… in fact… those Szekely citizens
are also his citizens.
Hungary Grants Citizenship Rights To Ethnic
Hungarians Abroad.
Yep, you heard that right.
All those Transylvanian-born Hungarians have
two passports, the right to study in Hungary
and, of course, vote at Hungarian elections.
This last thing is especially good for Orban.
He is popular inside of Hungarian borders,
but outside, he absolutely steals the show...
95% of Hungarians from abroad voted for his
party, the FIDESZ, at the latest legislative
elections.
Meanwhile, Romania considers those rights
for the Szekelys as a complete violation of
their own sovereignty.
In their opinion, if you vote in two different
countries, you can’t be loyal to the one
where you live.
All of this means the diplomatic relations
between Hungary and Romania are complicated...
Thanks to this, Orban can use Romania as an
antagonist to his nationalist propaganda.
And then Romania has a great chance to give
some Hungary some shit when it comes to European
politics.
And now you might be wondering…
What does the European Union think about all
of this?
The truth is that despite the Council of Europe
writing memorandums where they defend the
rights of ethnic minorities, Brussels would
never let Hungary win.
At the end of the day, Viktor Orban is like
Dracula, Frankenstein and Freddy Krueger of
European politics.
So, as long as things don’t turn ugly, don’t
expect any position from any EU institution
or politician.
But now this is your turn…
Do you think Transylvania should have its
own autonomy?
Or, perhaps, this is
nothing by a attempt from Hungary to get back
its sway on their former territories?
Please, leave your answer on the comment section
below.
Meanwhile, if you want to know more about
the old Romanian communist system and the
current Romanian corrupt system, don’t forget
to click on the video that appears at the
end of this one.
Also, visit RECONSIDER MEDIA.COM, the podcast
that provided the voices on this video that
are not mine.
And don’t forget that we publish brand new
videos every Monday and Every Thursday so
hit that subscribe button and you will not
miss any post.
If you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up and…
I wish you
a terrific Halloween!!!!